als ich jünger war habe ich immer fällt
bäume getragen aber die weideflächen
mein gott die leute kennt ihr das gefühl
ihr wacht am morgen auf und ich denke
ich portugal jetzt gerade habe ich
wieder so eine sache in meinem leben die
fakten mich richtig ab ich wünschte ich
wäre eine mega schokolade
habt ihr das gefühl schon mal habe ich
für meinen teil persönlich habe das
gefühl und nicht gehabt aber es sieht
alles so aus als hätte ich eine person
gefunden die das gefühl kennen denn ich
habe video gefunden eine frau die
wirklich so aussieht als würde sie jetzt
die transformation zur kaffeebohne
eingehen und wird schon noch mal rein
achtung angebotes alien im anmarsch
direkt vom planet sonnenbank
hofmarschall einfach das eigene kultur
alien wenn ihr diese person ihr seht
leute sagt marschall einfach was das
opfer ausdruck angekohlte say liegen
eigentlich bin ich weiß aber ich will
lieber super brown sein das ist doch
harmlos ja genau ok alles ja also sie
war irgendwann mal weiß okay warte ich
versuche mein bild zu finden
[Gelächter]
ok jetzt ja ich würde jetzt wieder wir
sind schlecht und jetzt lache aber okay
wir haben ist das gesehen was wir
gesehen haben und laut diesem bild was
jetzt hier gerade eingebildet leute
sieht wirklich so aus als würde sie die
transformation von menschen zum schoko
osterhasen wirklich absolut ernst nehmen
von wegen
eigentlich sieht sie so aus findet sich
so aber schöner und setzt sich dafür
gefährlichen gesundheitsrisiken aus also
okay ja also ich will ja nicht
übertreiben nicht übertrieben hätten ich
finde sagt mal ehrlich hat seine
kommentare 1
sie sieht gut aus auf der rechten seite
muss man sagen meistens solche leute
also ich will der barbie werden und dann
hauen die sich wirklich eine halbe tonne
an silikon in jeder brust rein und sehen
danach auswiesen die mülleimer aber sie
sieht tatsächlich noch recht okay aus
ich mache mir sorgen aber sie lässt
nicht mit sich reden
das ist die mutter
wissen wir nicht gedacht hab ich dachte
mir gerade eben kraft hanna so heißt das
mädchen ist ihr tier wird ein bisschen
heller geworden also zehner wenn diese
frau hier älter als dreißig ist solarium
süchtig und noch schlimmer das ist die
bizarre geschichte von henna tattoos er
hatte hannah tippen so gesagt
[Gelächter]
alles begann als britin hannah 18 ist
und im türkeiurlaub erstmal ist eine
richtig knackige sommerbräune bekommt
daraufhin versucht sie es erst mal mit
selbstbräuner er okay also die story war
quasi okay sie ist in urlaub gefahren
hat ist da braun geworden und dass man
von der sonne braun wird wunder wer
hätte es gedacht hat sie dann so
geschockt dass sie dass sie sich in eine
in einer duplo praline verwandeln will
sowas so was ist so schlimm
das muss ich wirklich einfach mal sagen
auch früher an meiner schule also ich
war früher einer gesamtschule da waren
auch noch so haupt und realschule
zusammen waren einige von dieser art wie
dieses mädchen auf der linken seite die
ja das ist wirklich das ist ein
verkohltes eleganz und stil steht total
auf solarium wenn dunlop ist seit zwei
jahren ihr freund und da in ihrer
nordirischen heimat stadt belfast nur
selten die sonne scheint gibt es das
jahres abo fürs studium also pop son si
prop son si die meisten leute in diesen
beiträgen von derart hier sind wirklich
schlimm schlimm
sie ist eigentlich noch ganz okay also
hier könnte man sagen okay zumindest
rein optisch hat das zumindest bisschen
was gebracht was wir haben zwölf minuten
position angefangen doch je dunkler du
wirst desto mehr verträgt du alle mails
die ich kenne tragen wegzuräumen oder
spray tans aber warum sollte ich make-up
aufspringen wenn ich ins solarium kann
also ich war ja für mich jetzt
eigentlich nicht zu weit aus dem fenster
lehnen ich bin kein mediziner auch kein
physiker aber weil das licht der
sonnenbank möglicherweise krebserregend
ist das aber auch keiner hinterfragt
warum sich alle in den schoko hase
verwandeln das ist eigentlich auch
interessant also die frage ist nicht
will ich das machen will ich zum mega
tafel werden dann die frage ist wie da
gibt es einmal die option aufsprühen und
die andere option des hautkrebs welche
wählen wir natürlich leute natürlich den
hautkrebs war ein make-up ihrer haut
nicht schaden würde
für heiner kein argument inzwischen ist
sie sogar solarium wichtig egal
die macht wirklich die macht wirklich
eine hautfarben transformation also
wirklich so langsam guck mich auf der
rechten seite so langsam sich das aus
nicht mehr hätte wäre sie europäischen
ursprungs sondern eher als hätte sie
also wirklich zu tief rennende
afrikanische wurzeln also so langsam ist
die schwelle von 3 überschritten und sie
ergibt langsam so ein eindruck als wäre
sie halt wirklich selbst bleibt es ist
nicht mehr so dass ich nicht nur besser
fühle mit tanz sondern ich bin
regelrecht abhängig davon
damit ist sie kein einzelfall leute und
es ist wieder das gleiche es ist die
gleiche geschichte wie so oft bei diesen
beiträgen dieser art ich glaube leute
ich sage es mal so ich glaube die
ursache hinter ganz ganz vielen von
diesen schönheitswahn vorstellung sei es
ich muss eine barbie sein
ich bin solar um süchtig sei es ich
mach's schönheitsoperationen oder hunger
nicht ab ist einfach ein sehr hoher
leidensdruck auf jungen frauen weltweit
schön auszusehen korrigiert mich oder
gibt mir recht wenn es anders sieht oder
genauso sieht wie ich aber wie gesagt
heute ich glaube es gibt einen sehr
hohen druck für mädels und frauen schön
auszusehen und manche zerbrechen glaube
ich an diesem druck und machen dann
sowas hier der münchner dermatologe
jürgen ellwanger erklärt die sonnenbank
sucht
natürlich gespannt die krankhafte
gesteigerte verlangen nämlich das
suchtverhalten nach künstlicher bräunung
zuletzt anorexie tantow ricke ich finde
ich finde leute dort jürgen ellwanger
sollte auch mal ihren nachnamen
kommentieren also was hat es damit
eigentlich aussicht ist hanna wirklich
ein sohn oder ist ja eine tochter
titelsong vergleichbar mit anderen
suchtverhalten wie alkoholismus oder
drogensucht titan im ungebremstes
verlangen nach das geht bei aber kraft
hat das so aufs gehirn wirken kann leute
also ich kenne so die grundlegende
funktionsweise von zum beispiel nikotin
zigaretten aber so ist schon klar also
dass wirklich mir das belohnungssystem
im hirn und da erwartet man das
eigentlich auch weil da ist es relativ
bekannter solche stoffe sucht erregend
sind deswegen sollten sie auch nicht
rauchen aber dass leute halt dem
sonnenstudio scheint eine ähnliche
situation kommt dass irgendwas was da
produziert wird ihnen das gibt was
andere dazu treibt irgendwie von alkohol
abhängig zu sein also das eigentlich
schon crazy von ihrem freund ben lässt
sie sich zur sogenannten bräunung
spritze verleiten hat sie injizieren
sich melanotan was die pigment
produktion anregt und die bräune
verstärkt ja ok ok also ich wollte sagen
an der steller steige ich aus stimmt
nicht ich bin weit vorher schon
ausgestiegen also warum das jetzt sein
muss geht mir auch nicht um einen kopf
wohl aber jetzt bin ich auch die
sonnenbank so richtig aber man kann sich
doch wirklich schon schwarz grillen auf
der sonnenbank oder nicht kann man doch
denken warum muss man sich da noch
irgendwas spritzen gut wenn wir jetzt
bei der schokoladen metapher bleiben
wollen dann wollte sie wahrscheinlich
einen kakao gehalt erhöhen von vollmilch
auf zartbitter jedoch illegal und
absolut gefährlich ist das blenden die
beiden wieder mal aus ich kenne keine
gesundheitlichen risiken von der spritze
und ich habe noch nichts schlimmes
gesehen
[Gelächter]
das ist ja auch ein geiler ansatz im
leben leute eine komplexe medizinische
thematik wie das ja und da sitzt einer
wahrscheinlich also erst gut ein punkt
vielleicht ist ja vielleicht wirkt so
ein bisschen einfacher gestrickt wir
haben also ganz ehrlich ich weiß nichts
von negativen folgen ich habe mich zwar
nicht damit aus
einander gesetzt aber egal und ich habe
auch noch nichts gesehen
jetzt den job haben sie zu ihrer wahl
rhein geleitet wird das ist jetzt
wirklich verkohlte stellen also das ist
so langsam muss ich sagen okay gut
jetzt können wir den stempel kann man
drauf machen fakultät alien level ist
erreicht als wett befürchtet dass das
krebserzeugende wirkung haben kann und
auch tatsächlich lebensgefährlich sein
kann
in meiner familie gibt schon krebsfälle
da hätten also manche manchen menschen
müssen müssen auch wirklich mit dem kopf
gegen die wand rennende muss sein oder
was war das erwartet meiner familie gibt
es schon einige fälle von krebs okay
lass mich eben mal zwei verschiedene
krebs wahrscheinlichkeit steigernde
dinge gleichzeitig tun und dabei noch
aussehen als würde ich nicht aus meiner
mutter sondern aus der lindt fabrik
kommt in meiner familie gibt schon
krebsfälle daher besteht auch ein
erhöhtes hautkrebsrisiko für mich aber
wenn man regelmäßig die leberflecken
solltet das okay sein sagte wer sagt
dass hanna du in dein freund vielleicht
auch irgendwelche mediziner leute die
tatsächlich ahnung haben die sowas sagen
für mich nicht zu weit aus dem fenster
lehnen aber es würde mich tatsächlich
wurde man habe leute wir uns ja immer
schon erfahren sachen die man nicht weiß
können einem auch nicht passieren
deswegen habe ich einfach jetzt aktiv
meine erinnerung und man wissen über die
schwerkraft gelöscht heißt wenn ich
demnächst in einem flugzeug sitzen
sollte und das abstützt wirkt einfach
die schwerkraft nur auf alle anderen und
nicht auf mich und ich bleib einfach
weiter in der luft schweben und fliegt
dann so einfach so in der hocke aber
ohne stuhl unter mir einfach bis zum
flughafen und lande alles gut also leute
schreibt dass morgen die kommentare an
kennt ihr diesen schönheits druck
empfindet ihr den wenn ihr mal so drüber
nachdenkt manchmal hat man solche sachen
noch nicht so präsent sondern bewegt die
erst mal drüber nachdenken wenn ja wenn
nein egal schreibt unten in den
kommentaren aber nicht hier und man kann
also über eine feucht vorgeschlagen das
video ab sonst kommt hat hätten so ein
bau
vorbei und verwandelt euch in eine
kinder schokolade